so this hexagon right over here the
whole thing is filled in with this pink
color so we'll say that this represents
one whole the whole thing is filled in
now what i want you to think about is
which of these other hexagons have
two-thirds filled in
so our goal is to identify the hexagons
that are two-thirds filled in
so pause the video now
so i assume you have given a go at it
you have tried to determine which of
these are two-thirds filled and now
let's work on this together
so when you when you're thinking in
terms of thirds and here we're thinking
in terms of two thirds literally
two-thirds
what we think about is dividing things
into three equal sections so let me see
if i can draw a hexagon
fairly well
so let me draw
the hexagon
and i'm going to try to split it up into
three equal sections
whoops i'm going to try to split it up
into three equal sections so this is the
center of the hexagon right over here
and so maybe that's one of the equal
sections
and then if i do one more line i split
it up into three equal sections one
two three it's actually kind of neat the
way that it's drawn it looks like a
three-dimensional cube but that was not
my intent my intent was to draw a
hexagon
so let me just so these each of these is
a third actually i could write this
that's one-third that's one-third and
this is one-third what we care about is
two-thirds so two of these one-thirds
and so let me clean this up a little bit
so i would fill in
i would fill in
one of the one-thirds and then two of
the one-thirds and this right over here
this hexagon that i've just drawn now
has two-thirds of it filled in
now i know what you're thinking all
right sal that would have been pretty
straightforward if these were divided
into thirds but these are not divided
into thirds each of these are divided
into one two three four five six equal
pieces this is divided into sixths how
do we figure out how many of the sixths
should be filled in in order to have the
same thing as two-thirds
well i would tell you
you don't worry too much all we have to
do is we can redraw this or we can we
can do a little bit of work here to
split this into a set of three equal
sections we can split into six equal
sections well how would we do that well
we take each of those three equal
sections and then split them into two
equal sections so this one right over
here i could split this into two equal
sections
this one right over here i could split
into two equal sections this one right
over here i can split into two equal
sections so i had three equal sections
before now each of them
have been split into twos and i have six
equal sections
so now the way i've drawn it i'm dealing
with sixths and how many sixths
represent the same
represent the same fraction as the two
thirds did well i still have my shaded
area i have one two
three
four sixths
so four sixths is the same thing as
two-thirds or another way to think about
it any of these that have four out of
the six equal sections filled in that
means that two-thirds of the sections
are filled in or i i i could say that
two-thirds of the hexagon is filled in
so let's just look at these so this one
we have one well let me do a color that
has a little more contrast so we have
one
two three four out of the six is filled
in four six are filled in that's the
same thing as two-thirds
so this one represents two-thirds this
one only has two of the six filled in so
it's not it's not four-sixths which has
to be two-thirds this is two-sixths we
want two-thirds this one is one two
three
four four of the six are filled in so
this is two-thirds so i will
put a square around that one
and this one has one
two
three four of the six filled in so this
is four sixths which we've already
figured out is the same thing
as
two thirds and we're done